many tanks gathered and put a link to
all of you yes yeah thank you to again
not in the Austrian presidency for their
trust
I'm grateful so for the confidence of
the 27 government's represented today
around the table The ministers confirmed
the unity which characterizes our day to
day work there's transparency there is a
willingness to come forward there are
different attitudes because of history
geographical proximity of the nature of
economic relations between various
Member States and the United Kingdom my
task force and I take account of these
differing sensitivities as we do in our
dings with European Parliament we're now
on the home straight since the meeting
of the 20th of July of the European
Council we've made progress on certain
subjects on the separation and orderly
withdrawal and thinking of Euratom
judicial cooperation procedures underway
the protection of personal data to be
exchanged before the end of the
transition period but we still have to
reach agreement on two portent chapters
governance the governance of the
agreement that has to be credible for
the agreement itself to be sound and
there are 3000 designations of origin
which are currently protected in the 28
member states of the European Union from
scotch whiskey to polish vodka via Greek
feta brexit must not lead to a loss of
intellectual property rights which are
associated with these geographical
designations of origin of course we also
have to make
that way decisively on the Irish
question proposal for the backstop on
Ireland and Northern Ireland has been on
the table since February it is an
insurance policy to avoid our border
between Ireland and Northern Ireland
whatever the future relationship will
bring it reflects our agreement with the
UK in December 2017 confirmed by Prime
Minister Theresa May in a letter to
President tusk in March we are ready to
improve this proposal work and the EU's
side is ongoing
we are clarifying which goods arriving
in Northern Ireland from the rest of the
UK would need to be checked and where
when and by whom these checks could be
performed we can also clarify that most
checks can take place away from the
border at the company premises or in the
markets we need to did rama tie the
checks that are needed this checks are
caused by the UK's decision to read you
it's single market and the customs union
what we need in the wisdom agreement is
a legally operational backstop which
fully respects the territorial integrity
of the UK this backstop will only apply
unless and until a better solution is
found in the context our future
relationship comedy Ghana has cannot
sent the European Council be meeting in
Salzburg tomorrow and the day after
tomorrow and the invitation of president
tusk I shall be able to present there
certain government along with present
Jonker the state of play in these
negotiations in a fairly precise manner
and with the view to that
I should merely like to thank you're not
in the ministers who took the floor
today to express their unfailing
solidarity towards Ireland in particular
that solidarity is shared by all the
European institutions in particular the
European Parliament as I've always said
this be my final point the European
Council October will be the moment of
truth it's then that we shall see
whether the agreement we're hoping for
is within our grasp thank you very much
much due to the fact